OK, you might remember this guy named William
Barr.
He is the attorney general.
After all, he's Donald Trump's hatchet man,
attorney general.
And he up until yesterday had all but completely
disappeared from the public eye since he attended
that White House super spreader event for
Donald Trump.
Supreme Court pick Amy CONI Barrett.
That was that event which set in motion this
chain of coronavirus cases.
Bar went missing for a while after that point
bar resurfaced yesterday to say without any
hesitation, at this point, there is no evidence
of widespread election fraud that would have
affected the election results in any way.
Now, you still have people saying, well, what
about this one vote?
A dead person really did vote.
The point is, there is no evidence at this
point of fraud of any materially significant
nature to the election.
You also immediately had counter articles
coming out saying, no, BAH didn't clear everybody
of fraud.
What Barr said is to date, there is no evidence
of materially significant election fraud.
He said this in an interview yesterday with
the Associated Press.
His exact statement was, quote, To date, to
date, we have not seen fraud on a scale that
could have affected a different outcome in
the election.
There has been one assertion that would be
systemic fraud, and that would be the claim
that machines were programed to skew the election
results.
And the DHS and DOJ have looked into that.
And so far, we haven't seen anything to substantiate
that as this was breaking.
Donald Trump tweeting, quote, I hope everybody
is watching away.
And right now, other media afraid to show
people are coming forward like never before.
Large truck carrying hundreds of thousands
of fraudulent fake ballots to a voting center.
Terrible save America.
So at this point, Donald Trump's claims are
sort of a running parallel commentary that's
completely divorced from all the facts on
the ground.
And then immediately after William Barr said
this, there was speculation that Donald Trump
was going to fire him because within moments
of that interview being published, a William
Barr was seen arriving at the White House
and the speculation was, oh, boy, Trump called
him in and he's going to fire him right now.
That's not at all what was going on.
That was a preplanned meeting with the chief
of staff, Mark Meadows.
CNN's Caitlin Collins reporting that, quote,
Attorney General Barr is in the West Wing
for a meeting with Mark Meadows.
An official says the meeting was planned before
his interview with the Associated Press.
Now, it certainly wouldn't be beyond Trump
to fire William Barr for saying this.
That would actually be totally unsurprising.
But the speculation that the timing of Barr
going to the White House after saying yesterday,
no evidence of election fraud, that was mere
speculation.
And he was actually there to meet with the
chief of staff, Mark Meadows.
Now, there are all sorts of other things going
on involving the Justice Department, some
not very good for Trump, which could have
been the reasons for William Barr or at least
the subject matter of William Barr's meeting
with Chief of Staff Mark Meadows.
Let's talk about one
of
those next.